hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 1 video
congratulations you made it all year
flash families back just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet so much stuff to talk about
so top 10 WTF number 10 is the one
episode flashpoint that was the biggest
surprise or one of the biggest surprises
there were a couple big twists that I
really liked and I like the way they're
using flashpoint to fix some of the
problems with its characters that go way
back to season one side effect of having
a TV show that can use time travel in a
believable way so however you feel about
them doing comic-book flashpoint just
think of this is flashpoint light I feel
like they hit all the big beats like
they hit the spirit of flashpoint Barry
had to come to terms with the
reverse-flash being allowed to kill his
mother needing to kill his mother in
order to fix everything or not fix
everything so to speak I'll explain what
the reverse-flash meant at the end of
the episode when he joked at Barry that
he would not be completely back to
normal but number 9 iris west one of the
big characters to get a huge fix going
back to season 1 she had all kinds of
character problems in season 1 and most
of it had to do with her character not
really having anything to do with the
actual plot of the series she was kind
of like the person that Barry pined
after it was really soapy maybe you
enjoyed that stuff there's nothing wrong
with that it's just that Candice Patton
pretty great actress can do a lot more
it's just a lot more fun to watch when
characters get to actively be involved
in plot progression so they had a couple
fun twists with genre tropes like the
superhero secret identity trope like
when they're on the date iris is like I
need to go like she comes up with a fake
excuse to run off to help Wally because
she knows that while he's the flash
she's been helping him out the thing
that she's doing to help out is just
using her position as news reporter and
access to information to help wall a
source and track down metahumans so
she's a much bigger part of team flash I
feel like during season 2 even you know
they were starting to correct her
character a little bit she was kind of
like the character that would stand
there and Cheer Barry on so now she's a
more active part of the plot and I think
it's going to be a lot better like I
don't mind them doing the relationship
II stuff as long as her character
actually has something to do
with plot progression but number 8 Joe
West if you've never watched the wire
flashpoint Joe West is kind of like
McNulty like a super drug somebody who's
actually a pretty good detective but his
personal problems just completely
overshadow his ability as a father and
as a police officer so like at the end
of the episode when he shoots the rival
to stop him from taking Barry down like
he's actually a good detective he did
the same thing he did in the pilot that
whole final fight was just a big easter
egg for the pilot episode with the
weather wizard tornadoes the actual
weather wizard named shout out in Joe
West killing the villain at the end too
if you haven't watched the pilot in a
long time Joe West shot weather wizard
at the end of that - so this is like a
Back to the Future style episode act to
the pilot future like all the way back
to that first episode post flashpoint
Joe seems like he's not quite as
terrible but he still has this real big
problem with iris so like they weren't
talking in flashpoint they're not
talking again now they said that's going
to be a big part of their arc this
season so they probably won't reveal why
iris hates Joe so much for a while and
it probably has something to do with her
mother you know some big family problem
something that goes so deep that it
couldn't be solved by like a simple
conversation but we also learned while
we're at the police station that the
captain is different - it is a huge
Easter Egg for the 90s flash series so
you know like they turned John Wesley
Shipp into Jay Garrick this is also an
actor from the 90s flash series he was
kind of like the Cisco Ramon of the 90s
series so now he's Barry's police
captain in his name Julio Mendez was the
same name of his character on the 90s
series so they just kind of like picked
him up via flashpoint and transplanted
him to present-day so just a huge easter
egg for the 90 series it was awesome
number six is Barry phoning it in for
the last three months when we go into
the police station the captain's like
have you found out who the rival is in
naturally he's the flash he's also a
really good CSI person so he's been
using his power to this whole time he
probably would have found out who he was
right away and the funny thing is is
that when he finally does confront the
rival he just rips his mask right off
like I don't even care I'll tell you who
I am my name is edward clariss
everybody gets really quiet
oh my god they're finally doing the
thing that's another big twist on the
way they tell stories on the TV show by
number five edward clariss is the rival
so this is one of the few twists where
they're not trying to bait and switch
I feel like them having him rip his mask
off is their way of telling you that
this isn't going to be one of the big
mysteries of the season like Harrison
wells
eobard thawne in season 1 in Jay Garrick
zoom in season 2 they're like we're not
gonna do that again we're just gonna rip
the masks off episode 1
dr. alchemy Savitt are those are going
to be the big mysteries of the season
but we haven't got the Savitt artis yet
we've only gotten dr. alchemy edward
clariss
is from the Golden Age flash comics he
debuted in 1949 in flash number 104 so
obviously this is a slight change the
character in that he's appearing in
modern-day but in the comics edward
clariss is called the rival he was the
reverse-flash of the Jay Garrick Golden
Age of the flash so when we got to the
Silver Age
that's when eobard thawne became the
reverse-flash so for a long time in the
comics every time they debuted a new
version of the flash they also debuted a
new version of the reverse flash but the
twist at the end of the episode is that
even post flashpoint he will probably
become the rival again because he's in
bed with someone that looks like his
wife so he seems like a totally normal
person but dr. alchemy sounds like he's
going to do something crazy to turn him
into the rival so number 4 reverse flash
flashpoint explainer this is a really
great moment just him against Barry
letting him know it's my turn to be the
hero you'll be begging me to kill your
mother by the end of this so the twist
in this moment is that the reverse
flight because like Barry is slowly kind
of breaking down the reverse flash has
to drag him back in time whereas like
the last time the reverse flash needed
to go back to his time Barry was the one
to throw him through the wormhole so
it's a nice twist on that not very much
in keeping with comic book flashpoint so
nothing new there but it will be fun to
see him joke about the Silence of the
Lambs torture basement that he was
keeping him in later so number three is
Elon Musk Cisco still has kind of a
sense of humor isn't completely terrible
so it was fun seeing that different
version of STAR Labs then seeing him
drag Caitlin in I'm sorry have I been
kidnapped
just completely adorable but we you know
we learned that even though Caitlyn is a
child doctor she's also really smart she
has the idea to use the cameras to find
the rival so like even in different
timelines there's still core aspects of
their characters that are the same that
was the whole deal with the lightning
rod so number two was like the big
action set piece where Barry
you know dissolves the tornadoes after
iris gives him the big speech that was
what they called their lightning rod
moment where Barry learns the iris is
his lightning rod that's also something
from the comics whereby like the flash
has kind of like a tether in the
multiverse
to a single character everybody has a
tether Barry's is iris that just kind of
helps him Center himself so he starts to
actually get stuff back that he's losing
because of flashpoint when she gives in
that speech so that's why the rivals
like this is impossible this is crazy
that you're able to do this but you've
been reading comics you probably knew
this like iris and Barry in every
version of the multiverse are together
in some way you know whether or not
they're actually married or they're just
dating or they only know each other
really well they're close friends
they'll always pop up in proximity to
each other in some way but number one
WTF dr. alchemy shows up in it's Tobin
bells voice they're doing the tonita
zoom voice thing where it's like a
really scary voice and it might be
someone else's face under the mask he
wakes edward clariss up calls to him and
it seems like he's going to turn him
into the rival or set him on a path to
taking down the other speedsters but no
idea how this is going to crossover with
the Savitt our plot line the big stuff I
know you're wondering about the
reverse-flash said where you're going to
find out whether or not things are
different so a lot of you have wondered
if maybe the reverse-flash did something
a little extra when he fixed flashpoint
to make things even worse for Barry
without him realizing it
we'll find out overtime like that's part
of the fun of the first half of the
season and especially the next episode
just learning what's gonna stick from
the flashpoint changes in what new
things are even more different so Joe
and iris are still on the outs Barry and
Cisco clearly have some drama between
them and I think that some of the new
speedsters will stick as well like we
know Jessie quicks going to be one of
the speedsters Wally doesn't seem like a
speedster in this moment
remains to be seen I just I feel like
they wouldn't make wall-e the flash and
then take that back right away
so let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and like what are you most excited for
based on the teases at the end of this I
know most of you are probably going
crazy about dr. alchemy he's going to be
a lot of fun and there's still just so
much stuff that they have to introduce
episode 2 will be when they roll out
most of the rest of the stuff but I
don't think that Jessie quake in
Harrison wells will be coming back till
episode 3
but really like the point of episode 2
is in introducing post flashpoint earth
like what is different now that has
stuck based on flash point changes so
just a reminder that there's a new round
of the giveaway going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video my
flash videos will work just like they
did last year arrow premieres tomorrow
so naturally I'll post that episode 1
video after it airs there's some new
Luke Cage that I'm still working on and
there's some cool Game of Thrones stuff
that's happening tomorrow so all that
stuff should post in the next day or so
but get hype we're back congratulations
everybody you made it all year flash
family is back well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that
really hardcore arrow trailer and you
can click here for the Iron Fist teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight